what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and if you have been wondering what
exactly is going to be happening with
Spider-Man and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe this is the video for you fans
right now have many questions when it
comes to Spider-Man like when exactly is
he going to be getting the Venom
symbiote that was teased in the
post-credits scene of Spider-Man no way
home if he's even still going to be
getting that suit at all we do know that
plans can change sometimes plus we know
that this is most likely the last
Spider-Man trilogy for Tom Holland so
what happens after that who is coming in
to replace him and what are the villains
that are going to be coming in to fight
against Spider-Man we'll answer all
these questions in this video including
when he is going to be getting that
symbiote suit Venom and yes based off of
everything we've heard he is going to be
getting that suit so we'll break it all
down in this video and if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest MCU
news and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items as well the winner gets
to pick one item and we pick a winner at
the end of each month so first and
foremost if you don't know it's been
reported that Tom Holland has signed a
new contract to play Spider-Man from
what we've heard this contract will
include three Spider-Man solo films so
the next Spider-Man trilogy and then
three team up projects now we already
know two of them Avengers King Dynasty
and Avengers Secret Wars the third one
however is unknown at this point in time
also Sony and Tom Holland himself have
recently stated that they have met and
they have talked about the Spider-Man 4
script now unfortunately this has been
put on hold due to the writer strikes
and the actor strikes but from what
insiders have told us the script sounds
pretty dang good at least what they
heard about it before the strike
happened it sounded pretty good then
which is great news however Spider-Man 4
isn't exactly going to show us
Spider-Man Tom Holland Spider-Man
getting the Venom symbiote it looks like
that is being saved to do something
extremely comic accurate which could
make fans extremely excited however
fortunately we might have to wait a few
movies before he gets that Venom
symbiote suit but it's okay because the
new Spider-Man trilogy that Tom Holland
has signed up for is going to go past
phase six so Tom Holland is going to
remain our Spider-Man in the MCU in
Phase 7 and in Phase 8. however it looks
like he is going to get the symbiote
suit in phase six but not in his solo
Spider-Man movie release dates are kind
of up in the air right now we don't
exactly know when Spider-Man 4 is going
to come out however we are assuming it's
going to come out before the King
Dynasty because that was the original
plan according to insiders which makes a
lot of sense because there is a lot of
Spider-Man story that we need to know
and see before we go into Kang Dynasty
where he teams up with the new Avengers
now originally when we knew that he was
going to get the Venom symbiote suit
thanks to that post credit scene and no
way home everybody freaked out thinking
the next Spider-Man film was going to be
venom and maybe even Tom Hardy's Venom
but then of course they took Tom Hardy's
Venom back to the Sony universe but we
still had remnants of the symbioteer so
we knew he was going to get the suit
however once we heard about Avengers
Secret Wars we thought wow it would
actually be really cool if he got the
suit then because that's when he gets it
for the very first time in the comics
during the events of Avengers Secret
Wars and it looks like that is the plan
for Marvel Studios and Spider-Man for
him to receive the Venom symbiote during
the events of Secret Wars and according
to Charles Murphy at Murphy's
multiverse.com he has heard that this is
indeed their plan so we won't see a
Venom symbiote in the next Spider-Man
film at least we won't see it attached
to Spider-Man maybe in a post-credits
scene but we do know now when he is
going to fully Dawn this new suit the
Venom symbiote attached to him and that
is going to be in secret Wars and this
offers us kind of a more accurate comic
story that we're used to unlike in venom
in the Sony spider verse that changed
the comic origin but having the Symbiote
attached to Spider-Man first and the MCU
and then Spider-Man reject it and then
it go to Eddie Brock that's what we've
all been expecting and it looks like
that is indeed what is going to happen
starting in Phase seven because Peter
will get the suit in phase six in secret
Wars and that is obviously the last
project of phase six so Tom Holland
Spider-Man is going to be around in
Phase seven and phase eight hopefully
however he is going to have a
predecessor that is going to continue to
be a Spider-Man in the MCU we talked
about who is going to replace him and as
far as we know miles moral is a
live-action Miles Morales is going to
replace Peter Parker this seems to be
Marvel's plan now Sony has already
confirmed that they are working on a
live-action Miles Morales movie right
now we're kind of unsure if this is
going to be a project with the MCU or
just a Sony project alone however we
have heard recently from many insiders
that Marvel Studios is planning on Miles
Morales entering the next Spider-Man
film and a lot of us were already
thinking about this before the reports
came in because of one important thing
in Spider-Man no way home and that is
Feast the organization that Aunt May
volunteered at well for those who know
the story that is where and how Peter
Parker and Miles Morales could meet in
the MCU the feast organization could
continue you Miles Morales could
volunteer there and Peter Parker could
volunteer there since that's what Aunt
May love to do she ran feast and now
that she's gone he could want to
volunteer there and spend his time there
and this is a really good setup because
it sets everything up for Peter to be
the mentor to miles one thing that fans
kind of complained about with the
Spider-Man homecoming Trilogy is that
Peter Parker was never really on his own
he always had help he always had
somebody kind of parenting him at first
it was Robert Downey Jr's Iron Man and
then it was happy and then we got the
other two Spider-Man but now that nobody
really knows who he is nobody knows
Peter Parker is Spider-Man he's on his
own and if miles comes in it's time for
him to step up and then he becomes the
mentor this is what fans have been
waiting for so we could get a more
mature more grown up Spider-Man and we
could also get a training Miles Morales
and over the course of three films if
Peter Parker continues to train miles he
could be our new Spider-Man after the
next Spider-Man trilogy ends with Tom
Holland and he moves on from the MCU but
there is a lot to look forward to until
that time after actually happens for
example they are building up for
Spider-Man to finally take on Kingpin
and what looks to be an official
Sinister Six at some point in time
Marvel Studios is building up Kingpin in
a really big way we've already had him
introduced in the Hawkeye series he's
coming back in the Echo series and of
course he's going to be a main villain
in the Daredevil series but from what
we've heard in the Daredevil series he's
actually going to be running for and
then will eventually become mayor of New
York City this sets Kingpin up to be a
major player because now he is going to
have a ton of resources and a ton of
people behind him and from what we've
heard he's going to crack down on the
city's Vigilantes superheroes like
Daredevil and it looks like Spider-Man
this sets up Kingpin to be a major
player in the MCU in a really big way
because he'll then be a villain not just
for Spider-Man and not just for
Daredevil but eventually all of them and
it looks like they could all come
together to fight Kingpin and it looks
like Spider-Man might have a little bit
of help when it comes comes down to
fighting The Sinister Six however it
doesn't look like we're going to be
seeing these people appear all at once
in the First new Spider-Man film in
Spider-Man 4 but what will most likely
happen is these villains will start to
be introduced and Kingpin will start to
recruit them the Sinister Six will most
likely be the final Tom Holland
Spider-Man film Spider-Man 6. and by the
time we get there hopefully he would
have already teamed up with these other
Heroes and have fought many battles with
them going up against Kingpin and then
ultimately the final battle will be just
him because while we definitely want to
see Spider-Man team up with these other
characters like Miles Morales and
Daredevil and possibly characters like
She-Hulk we definitely want to see
Spider-Man on his own defeating the
villain by himself even if it's a big
Sinister Six fight and other Heroes kind
of help him out a little bit but then
ultimately he is the one to fight
Kingpin one-on-one and defeat him that's
what we want to see Spider-Man truly on
his own and winning on his own and it
looks like that is indeed what Marvel
Studios is setting up for the future of
Spider-Man including him getting the
Venom symbiote suit in Avengers Secret
Wars which is so cool to think about
since that is what happens in the comics
and let's hope that the stories for
Spider-Man in his own movies and in the
group movies are just really good and
Tom Holland Spider-Man goes out with the
bank but let us know what you think
about all of this in the comments down
below and let us know how excited you
are for the future of Tom Holland's
Spider-Man don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest Spider-Man and
MCU news you can also follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf
me